[Musique]
halloween c'est ce jeudi à 31 octobre si
vous n'avez pas encore billets de
déguisements nous allons vous en
proposer c'est parti
quelles sont les grandes tendances de
cette année a pour l'halloween pour nous
aiguiller océane est à mes côtés à
l'évent 2 dans ce magasin vend pas alors
quelles sont les grosses tendances déjà
chez les enfants chez les enfants cette
année on a pour les jeunes filles
le déguisement de sorcière nos
traditionnels voilà très glissante on a
plein de modèles en magasin du coup et
pour les jeunes hommes du coup ce sera
le déguisement de clown donc
combinaisons et masques
ça fait peur ça fait peur alors au
niveau des accessoires aussi on peut
customiser sa tenue moi je sais
exactement comme par exemple on a des
serre-têtes si certaines le diable on a
du maquillage du latex du faux sang du
la crème de maquillage on a des masques
en latex de la laque pour cheveux aussi
est le meilleur mais les lentilles on a
des douleurs à différents types de
l'anlci en magasin bon je vais tester
tout ça je vais me promener dans la
boutique
ouais je sais trop un déguisement pour
halloween n'y a pas de problème
[Musique]
alors si on n'aime pas se déguiser pour
halloween à ce qui a quand même la
possibilité de fêter cette fête
bah oui absolument vous pouvez faire par
exemple des tables ont prix moyen d'une
table c'est à peu près 60 euros en
comptant le nappage le chemin de table
les assiettes sont les maîtres quelques
décorations sur la table vous pouvez
mettre par exemple des doigts on a des
doigts et doigts coupés
ça fait peur ça fait près d'un an vient
on a des petites bougies des petites
bougies à l'aide si vous voulez mettre
petite bougie à l'aide
on a les serviettes les gobelets en fait
c'est un ensemble qu'on fait avec tout
le package en fait
[Musique]
ici dans cette boutique on vend autant à
halloween qu'à noël ou au jour de l'an
moi j'ai trouvé mon costume